welcome just wipe here's what we've got
beyond this week's show
Kip checks into a hotel of the future
where the staff understand 27 languages
the tech entrepreneur behind Mumsnet
tells me how the site has saved lives
and Lucy brings us a mythical adventure
with a wolf's goddess no less that's
also come for you after a quick look at
the tech stories that got us talking
this week Apple is snapping up Shazam
the uk-based song recognition app we
don't know the size of the deal but some
reports estimate the price tag was
around 299 million pounds one of the
oldest names in the british games
industry
Codemasters could be about to take its
shares public the company produces games
including Formula One's range for the
ps4 Sky News has learnt Codemasters
owner has approached banks about a
public listing in the coming months
Facebook's responded to criticism made
by former employee Chamath pally happier
who accused the tech giants of ripping
apart the social fabric of how society
works the firm says he hasn't worked
there for more than six years and
they've realized how their
responsibilities have grown since then
and at pilots been getting festive over
Germany by flying in the shape of a
Christmas tree
the captain traced the pattern from
Hamburg as far as Stuttgart before
returning five hours later now what
matters to you most when you stay in a
hotel cleanliness quality of the food
responsiveness of the chatbot concierge
all the staffs ability to translate your
requests into 27 languages well that
could soon be your top consideration as
kit found out
Hotels big buildings full of small
brooms connected by endless corridors
they may all look suspiciously similar
but this one is different it's been used
as a testing ground for tech startups to
see how their new inventions go down
with paying guests hundreds of companies
from 24 different countries applied for
the chance to trial their gadgets here
from in-room information projectors to
relaxation headsets and I've come to see
the three finalists in action
my mother click the word first truly
Wireless hearing never people to
communicate simultaneously you see you
know you know a darthian must get on
there yes we can absolutely get you a
bigger room just hold on we could have
27 people all speaking different
languages and get it translated
simultaneously no other translation
system in the market currently can do
that and once you've had your check in
chat translated in real-time it's time
to head up to the room where the next
innovation is waiting oh hi jiffy
started life as a way to book hotel
rooms in facebook but is morphed into a
chatbot concierge service i defuse a
chat bot that replies on a real-time
basis to frequently asked questions of
guests hotels are trying to engage more
and more guests to increase the number
of direct bookings you can ask it basic
questions and even request extra items
for your room although they're delivered
by human not thank you very much that's
great the final bit of tech on show here
at the Marriott testbed program is opti
shower a way of guest to earn food
vouchers by cutting down on their rooms
water and power usage but are these kind
of aids really necessary will many see
them as gimmicks hotel they're caught in
between sort of having their their core
customers that might want some more
traditional experience and perhaps
millennial customers who want to
experience the hotel in different ways
what if technology is discrete and you
almost don't notice it and it's there
for those at once you
then I think it can definitely work well
the hotels trial in this tech will be
hoping that their desire to innovate
doesn't end up putting off some of their
more private and less tech-savvy
customers give out your Sky News it's
nearly Christmas that time of year that
children love and parents deal with it
got us thinking about how technology has
influenced Parenthood since we were
young parenting websites like Mumsnet
have become institutions and according
to its founder the site has also helped
save lives it's been nearly 18 years
since Justine Robert set up a website to
help make parents lives easier by
swapping tips and sharing experiences
now Mumsnet has its own network of
vloggers and experts posting videos
about everything from makeup how to's
better to start soft and build up all
the way to the preparation so now we're
going to roughly chop it
it seems Tech has changed the parenting
experience too when we started Mumsnet
we were on dial-up and so it was just a
very frustrating experience for if you
remember that but I think the really big
change has been the introduction for
smartphone and for a website like us it
means you know people can access Mumsnet
for the advice it provides all the time
but it also has huge number of
challenges around being constantly
distracted and I think for parents you
know I'm negotiating that and the
slightly addictive nature and family
life has been the big challenge I'm
given that everybody's using their
phones now constantly how do you control
any warring mothers or abuse going back
and forth
I don't really recognize this warring
mother's business but clearly in you
know we've got 30,000 posts a day 12
million users clearly there are going to
be disagreements and some of those users
are extremely tired and fraught but we
asked I users and our community to
report stuff that breaks our guidelines
so that if you'd like they are the first
line of defense and then we look at
everything that's that's reported we do
that usually
well certainly within 24 hours these
days I'm thrilled that I'm going to
become a grandmother I really can't wait
over the years the site's become popular
with high-profile figures keen to reach
the Mumsnet audience now politicians
seem to enjoy having a good relationship
with moms now why do you think that is
the 2010 election was the sort of peak
of that where I think every politician
suddenly thought oh my god I've got to
be seen to be doing social media and
there's this big audience of women who
we think might be more swayable thank
you very much for letting me come on
line and answer as many questions I
could we had all the big minister's
opposition and government then after
election they go quite quiet Ashley so
really they're after votes they
mistakenly think that audience is all
going to vote the same way which has
never been the case and that women are
only interested in childcare is there
anywhere where you think moms are still
getting a raw deal well there is no
question our users think there is a
motherhood penalty in their employment
prospects so 9 out of 10 report that
they understand what is meant by
motherhood penalty either they're less
likely to get promoted or they're
actively discriminated against when
they're on maternity leave for the users
all 12 million of them talking to each
other on mums net has also led to some
life-saving moments we've had several
situations at topic pregnant pregnancies
being diagnosed and people being told in
no uncertain terms get yourself to a
hospital right now we recognise these
symptoms you need to go and you know
literally they got there within a couple
of hours of disaster we've had people
who are in extreme situations whether
it's domestic violence or you know
mental health crises who've had their
hands held through all that kind of
trauma so yes mums that has saved lives
definitely there's no question about it
video games time now and although this
time of year can be fairly quiet when it
comes to new games our reviewer Lucy
hasn't led us down here she is with her
views on three new releases economy is a
very special game and originally came
out on the PlayStation 2
and now it's coming out again on the
Xbox one Playstation 4 and PC so in the
game you play as the sun goddess
amaterasu you take the form of a wolf
and the game looks beautiful this is
inspired by kind of old Japanese ink
wash paintings and so the whole premise
of the game is as the sun goddess
amaterasu you're walking around the land
of Nippon and all of the color has been
sucked out of it you know these lush
green fields and now barren and gray and
brown and you discover that there are
these demons that are there sucking all
the joy and life out of the lab you can
interact all the animals and it's just
an incredibly beautiful game which has
all these aspects of puzzle solving
using your brush techniques you have
platforming so jumping around these
villages and interacting with the people
that you meet there and I definitely
recommend you figure out this Christmas
another remaster coming out this week is
loca Roco 212 blog getting from one end
of the level to the next but you don't
really control the blobs you control the
environment around them so you have to
kind of using the buttons you have to
tilt the world tilt the environment and
in doing so you can make the local roe
cows go like kind of tumble down using
physics we can make them jump so it's a
really cool tape on a platformer and if
you want to kind of chilled out
experience this Christmas with a game
that has an incredible soundtrack
definitely take a look at low Cobra -
really Resident Evil is of course an
incredibly famous series of survival
horror games but in recent years the
entries have kind of veered away from
survival horror and they've been more
action focused and a lot of core fans
haven't necessarily been happy with that
but Resident Evil 7 takes the series
back to its survival horror roots
seriously this is the scariest
installment of the Resident Evil series
and what Resident Evil 7 does so well is
how it builds tension and it is
legitimately terrifying there's a lot of
jump scares in there so it's maybe not
for the faint-hearted but it manages to
create this environment where you are
constantly on edge and it's a fantastic
game this week they're coming out with
the gold edition which includes Resident
Evil 7 the full game and all of the DLC
so that includes band footage 1 & 2 end
of Zowie which includes some brand new
areas for you to wander around in and
not a hero
which features Resident Evil like main
man Chris Redfield so if you if you
missed out number still evil 7 earlier
this year
definitely pick up the gold edition
because you get all of those good
we've reached the end of the show thank
you for joining us as always I'll be
back with more swype next week with a
festive special for you in the meantime
follow us on Twitter at Sky News white
ba-bye